so after a week highlighted by
Democratic debates president Trump
finally getting his chance to respond
the president not holding back at a
rally in Ohio by unleashing on his 2020
rivals Trump singling out Elizabeth
Warren and Joe Biden while also going
after their party's progressive policies
watch while Republicans are working
everyday to build up our country the
rage-filled democrat party is trying to
tear America apart the great Pocahontas
who's now lying and cheating her way to
the presidency if possible she said she
was Indian and I said that I have more
Indian blood than she does and I have
none I'm sorry for the last 20 years
China has taken hundreds and hundreds of
billions of dollars out of our country
they would love to see a guy like sleepy
Joe Biden who has no clue what the hell
he's doing
[Music]
they'd say too sleepy Joe sure just sign
right there okay and the president not
backing down in the battle over
Baltimore he instead up the ante by
criticizing how Democrats are running
other American cities no one is paid a
higher price for the far-left
destructive agenda than Americans living
in our nation's inner cities we spend
billions and billions and billions for
years and years and years and it's
stolen money and it's wasted money and
it's a shame the conditions and Nancy
Pelosi
once great city of San Francisco are
deplorable they're deplorable look at
Los Angeles with the tents and the
horrible horrible disgusting conditions
look at San Francisco
alright the president Emily seizing back
the national conversation after two long
nights of democratic debates he did
indeed I think it was really wise that
he didn't name the squad by their
individual names because it removed the
ball from their court the media didn't
go running immediately to them to say
what's your response I
think it was also smart for him to kind
of continue strategically this culture
where where he's driving that wedge
between the urban and suburban voters I
think it was huge but he highlighted the
waste of spending on these inner cities
because as the Democrats right now are
putting all their policies forth and how
much money they're going to dump into
continuing to solve or address these
problems he's highlighting all of this
money that's going to it hasn't fixed a
thing he should be careful however not
to alienate those suburban voters that
identify with those cities that they
that they live near but it is
interesting because if the president
brings it up Gregg then the media will
talk about it of course on the cities
yes and that's why that's why they
should be thanking him because because
he's shining a light on a problem that's
been around for decades if you look at
any devastated city chances are you'll
see it the Democrat machinery behind it
but the big loser from last night was
CNN because there was no chant and they
were a day where you could tell how
crestfallen they were when no chance
showed up because then what is gonna be
their prime-time lineup what is Don
Lemon gonna report on his might have to
do the news hard to believe I think the
big contrast is the the rally and the
debates so you witnessing this positive
energy which is actually derived from
real data I mean like you can't be happy
if the economy sucks so you're seeing
this rally right and everybody's having
a good time then you look up at this at
the stage of Tuesday and Wednesday and
it's a doomsday cult so on one side you
got happy feet on the other side you got
Soylent Green and I think that one of
them is a delusion and and in the data
backs up one side the other side
it's a feeling so it's it's data versus
a field it wasn't just the debates Capri
it really carried in - you had
Democratic leaning pundits or guests
writing articles or tweets or even being
on air including Paul Begala who was on
CNN saying he watched the debates and he
felt like basically they were setting up
President Trump to win and not doing a
good enough job for themselves dan Balz
saying that the Democrats put their
worst face forward how do you think the
debates went well I know that this is a
topic that's gonna probably get a touch
upon time and again throughout this hour
but I mean as a Democrat it was
incredibly frustrating I'm sure it's
probably no surprise to anyone around
this table or viewers at home
Tuesday night was more of my cup of tea
than the Wednesday evening well because
there actually was at least some
conversation between the idealists and
the pragmatist who actually did have
pragmatists on the stage as opposed to
Democrats going after one another
on Wednesday evening which just is not a
good look for us and does make us you
know weak overall I want to go back to
this issue though very quickly about
about the inner cities there's
interesting because you know I just I
took a look at this out of the hundred
CID top hundred cities only thirty of
those cities are actually have
Republican mayor's so the question is is
this you know an issue of correlation or
causality with Democrats because there's
no question that there are big Democrat
cities with Democratic mayors that are
failing but there are also rural areas
that are lagging and everything from you
know life expectancy to educational
attainment and everything else and as
someone who represented a rural area as
well as suburban and urban Democrats if
we paid any attention to rural
communities they are so forgotten
there's so many people out there if we
just paid attention to them it's
interesting as conservatives but
conservatives also Brian on the flip
side they also say if we would just pay
a little bit of attention to the urban
areas they could see into Greg's point
he's made it before not necessary on
this show yet but if you have both
parties working together or at least
competing against each other within a
city but if you have one-party rule in
either way it doesn't work both it but
it would be good at both parties ignore
it Brian
okay right go for the independent yeah
go for them and the Raelians in terms of
religious sect a couple of things Emily
what you said is right I believe that
when the president pointed out not
naming the names is correct when the
president goes ahead and says Urban's of
the problem look who's running these
cities look who's in charge right but
the president's got to go to the next
step
tell me what you do don't you say look
how bad these cities are give these
people hope and maybe the hope is the
opportunity zones because I hear they
are producing results Bend you Ben
Carson's its worst PR agent he's doing a
lot of great things but just doesn't get
the word out so now Ben Carson over the
last three days had his finest week of
as HS HSS secretary HUD secretary
because he's coming out and he said he's
using Baltimore as an opportunity so hey
mr. e let me
in charge of Baltimore I see the
potential in the urban areas I see how
people have underwhelming underwhelming
hopes for you and Christine in the first
night of the debates the Democrats
didn't even bring up they are in Detroit
yeah and they didn't even bring up
cities but can I ask you one other thing
made me quickly around the table the
president Rhee upped his focus on
Elizabeth Warren
yeah and for Democrats who thought that
the scandal of her heritage was behind
her he was reminding that's like he's
again he's like Lynyrd Skynyrd and
that's his free bird you know he when he
gets out there he's gonna play the hits
and it always works can I bring up just
one tangential think you know it is a
proc II it's coming back to the United
States I wish I knew who that was well
you know it's an interesting story
behind this is that he's a rapper I mean
I Trump brutally and the guy who's
helping him come back is Trump and
that's an interesting story that people
should focus also he's coming back
because he's innocent I think but yeah
well he had a he watched the video
because this guy's gotten a raw deal he
picked up the phone call the head of
Sweden he goes we have to go through a
process next thing you know he's about
heading home Kim Kardashian actually
picked up the phone and talked to him
and here's the thing about the president
people who get to know him understand
and that I probably didn't make clear to
Juan last night is that people that know
him say they know for sure he's on a
race there's nothing about him there's
races sometimes he can be a racially
insensitive as Tim Scott pointed out
here's another example he sees a person
in trouble he doesn't see a black person
in trouble and that's when people
haven't understand he wouldnt have to
Elijah Cummings because Elijah Cummings
went after his Kevin Mack Elena it
wasn't because Elijah Cummings is black
that's what people and other networks
and and other parties have trouble
understanding you don't hurt his
feelings because he knows he's not our
what he's going after Elizabeth Warren
is Pocahontas because at least he's this
is how I think Elizabeth Warren will
frame it he's afraid
but like all the zoo you know every time
you get a nickname from from President
Trump it means you get some street
credibility you're gonna go out and
fundraise on it so you know if he's good
if he's resurrecting Pocahontas as his
free bird I think it's unfortunate it's
it plays into Elizabeth Warren's hand I
suggest Emily layoffs do you want to
make a musical reference before we go to
break well it's just like when I was at
the slash concert the other night and
they played night train right everyone
loved it it was allowed
the crowd was cuz they're Guns N'Roses
hit the president is the president of
every one right and so it goes against
unfortunately the narrative that a lot
on the Left have clung to which is no
he's a racist no matter what but this
example will serve only potentially
persuasively to those who are on the
fence or who are open to rational reason
all right yeah I only hope that if Brian
Kilmeade ever gets stuck in a foreign
jail President Trump does not try to
intervene and doesn't try to look at the
video I want you to rock Brian just
don't go overseas